what was taken from me so many many
years ago my
dignity my destiny my blood and he
kisses her or maybe she kisses him just
goes to show that some things are better
not kept in the family but it is
actually Caroline's family that pulls
her out of this she has a vision of her
dead mother causing her to change her
tune climb through the swarm of bees and
destroy the paintings of robai and his
girlfriend with ironically a hook the
tool that Candyman used to apart so many
of his countless victims she also knocks
over some candles setting the whole
display on fire just as Candyman was set
a blaze all of those years AG Gap
burning the paintings also sets his
Spirit on fire and he burns in agony
once
more and Caroline feels that she has
finally ended the 136 Year Legacy of the
Candyman